und jetzt kann ich mit einem der
erstunterzeichner des offenen briefes an
den bundeskanzler sprechen es ist
professor harald welzer gewaltforscher
und sozialpsychologen abend
professor welter sie appellieren ja in
dem brief dass einhell zitat kompromiss
den beide seiten akzeptieren können
zitat ende gefunden werden soll welcher
kompromiss könnte das sein
ich glaube wir können nicht sagen
welcher kompromissen am ende gefunden
werden muss weil die aushandlung müssen
die beteiligten parteien machen uns
kommt es darauf an zu sagen wir brauchen
ein fenster eine unterbrechung der
gewalteskalation damit überhaupt eine
verhandlung stattfinden kann in der ein
kompromiss erarbeitet werden kann im
moment sind wir sozusagen nur in der
logik der steigerung von gewalt und das
kann nicht zielführend sein warum denken
sie dass verfährt zeit für dieses
fenster ist vor kriegsbeginn war unter
anderem urlaub schon
jetzt gerade erst der un generalsekretär
in moskau und versucht zu sprechen mit
wladimir putin und auch über
waffenstillstand oder frieden zu reden
ja ich würde sagen wir befinden uns im
moment in einer fatalen logik weil
kriegsgewalt selber die eigenschaft hat
sich zu dynamisieren das heißt wir haben
eine ständige abfolge von aktionen
reaktion aktion reaktion und immer eine
steigerung im rahmen des nächsten
schrittes und diese logik führt
fatalerweise
möglicherweise dazu dass der krieg zu
einem großen krieg wird sich also
entgrenzt oder im minderschweren fall
sich auf dauer stellt und auf ein
jahrelang vermögens und abnutzungskrieg
hinausläuft und damit ist überhaupt
keiner einzigen partei gedient und
insofern ist es glaube ich jetzt wo die
sache auch schon so weit
vorangeschritten ist aber wie lange
keine verhandlungen effektiv gesehen
haben vielleicht muss man nach neuer
akteure ins spiel bringen ist diese
unterbrechung einfach absolut notwendig
streiten sich eigentlich in ukraine der
ukrainischen regierung auch den ab zu
verhandeln
wir sind das um lippenbekenntnisse
das kann ich steht mir auch nicht um das
zu beurteilen weil wir stecken weder
neben dem strategien von herrn seelands
die noch in der psyche von herrn putin
drin wir stecken aber vermittelt in
einer gewalteskalation in einer
kriegerischen gewalt dynamik und diese
dynamik muss unterbrochen werden bei
wenn dieser krieg sich entgrenzt ist
auch den angegriffenen ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer in keiner weise geholfen ja das
ist klar also dann ist in ukraine nicht
geholfen aber die ukraine die sind jetzt
ja damit beschäftigt zu kämpfen die
bleiben freiwillig im land die wollen
tatsächlich ihr land verteidigen wie
wirkt denn dann so einen brief oder so
ein appell auf die
also man muss er unterschreiben es gibt
die perspektive der angegriffenen opfer
und diese perspektive dek dek steht
einem überhaupt nicht zugehen
irgendeiner weise zu kritisieren die
braucht auch keine rechtfertigung aber
sie ist nicht identisch mit der
perspektive einer internationalen
politik die sich über kriegsziele
rechenschaft ablegen muss die sich über
eine ordnung nach diesem krieg in
rechenschaft ablegen muss über das was
in ihren gesellschaften passiert
rechenschaft ablegen muss und das größte
interesse haben kann dass dieser krieg
nicht zu einem weltkrieg eskaliert und
die gefahr besteht objektiv dh wir haben
zwei verschiedene logischen und wir
machen gerade den fehler dass die logik
zwei verschiedene in eins gesetzt wird
und daraus sich immer weitere
forderungen ableiten
[Musik]
sozialpsychologe
jemanden etwas zu geben also putin jetzt
etwas an waffen schiltern oder ein stück
ukraine unser denken und für hoffen
gehört damit auf
es macht mindestens genauso viel sinn
wie alle anderen varianten
wir können uns da nicht hineinversetzen
und niemand kann im moment eine
belastbare prognose abgeben aber in
einer situation wo man keine belastbare
prognose abgeben kann tut man doch gut
daran die sicherste variante
dh es nicht auf eine eskalation des
kriegsgeschehens ankommen zu lassen
sondern zu versuchen zu verzögern oder
diese ich nenne das den spalt sozusagen
in die gewalt zuzuschlagen damit man
einen raum hat in dem andere
gesichtspunkte vielleicht auch andere
möglichkeiten des handelns überhaupt
wieder zur geltung kommen können ok
jetzt ist zeit für verhandlungen nach
einem waffenstillstand zu suchen das
sagt professor harald welzer einer der
erstunterzeichner des offenen briefes an
dem bundeskanzler danke für ihre meinung
und einschätzung
danke sehr